en france les frères grimm sont
d'illustrés inconnus on se souvient
vaguement qu'on leur doit certains des
plus fameux conte pour les enfants
rassemblés en un volume de la collection
de poche
gf flammarion dans la traduction
classique d'armelle guern jacob et
wilhelm grimm sont des contemporains de
lamartine
ils sont nés dans la province de s au
centre de l'allemagne peu avant la
révolution
tous deux linguistes et historien il
joue un rôle considérable dans
l'affirmation de la culture allemande
c'est à ce titre qu'il se préoccupe de
réunir les contes traditionnels du
folklore allemand alors disséminés en
une multitude de petits états autonome
et seulement consacré par la tradition
orale
les frères grimm recueil et transcrivent
plus de 200 comptes qui vont connaître
une faveur universel le petit chaperon
rouge tom pouce blanche neige cendrillon
la belle au bois dormant
on oublie souvent qu'ils les ont composé
j'avoue une prédilection particulière
pour deux d'entre eux le petit tailleur
d'abord loges malicieux de
l'intelligence qui triomphe de la force
brute grâce à un sens certain de ce que
l'on appelle pas encore la dialectique
et les musiciens de brême dans lequel
des animaux peu doué pour l'harmonie
font une musique qui leur plaît à eux et
vivre heureux de la sorte